Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Well,
that brings up this the thing that's going on this week with Conor McGregor.
We got caught off guard last episode.
Jamie and I were talking and just out of nowhere,
it's just breaking news.
And Jamie brought it up.
The Conor announced his retirement and I said,
I thought he was trolling you.
And I had the exact same reaction.
I was like,
he's trolling,
he's fucking around.
It's all weird.
He wouldn't,
he'd be more eloquent than that.
He'd be,
he blew it up,
put it out better than that.
But,
and then the news started coming out and I also started thinking,
well,
maybe,
maybe something happened in training or maybe it was because of that guy that
died recently and people were saying,
you know,
they were shocked that I didn't know the full details and the guy's death.
Honestly,
with things like this,
like you know what's going to happen and um,
it's unavoidable.
It's,
there's a certain amount of risk involved in any extreme sport.
Plus that's the exception.
Yeah.
It's going to happen.
That's the exception.
It is like seeing mad at peanut butter when someone dies.
It's like,
I'm still gonna eat peanut,
you know,
it is exception,
but I was waiting for all the details come out.
I don't think they've done an autopsy yet.
They don't think they know.
I don't either.
I and I,
I didn't think that with Connor and I don't know if this is,
I don't think it's sharing too much information.
When Khan and I had lunch together,
I just talked to and he kept bringing up is a reoccurring theme when we were
talking,
he goes,
the the media man,
like for this,
it's such a beast.
He's like,
like I've done interviews before,
but you know,
it's different.
Like he's not a guy where when any other fighter sit down and do an interview,
they're really not selling the fight the time about their camp and they're doing
the same thing over and over and Connor's up fucking master that we've never
seen do it before.
So he's coming up with original content nonstop.
He's on.
You know,
like when,
when he came on our podcasts,
he,
you could,
he was on,
he did the whole car wash.
He was exhausted and then we came down.
You could tell him he was thinking and just start spitting out gold.
He's just a beast man.
So to have that guy fly around the world and do all this shit,
I mean at the end of the day we got to remember this is a sport,
this is not the WWE.
So to keep putting on the spectacle,
like it's similar to WWE at some point yesterday,
man,
what these guys do is it's a real,
real,
we're in the HERP business.
He has to focus man.
And I just feel like,
I think Connor's to blame,
to Dana's to blame.
I think both of them just need to talk because if Connor before it's bad
planning him bad playing on Dana,
if he just went do,
listen,
I've sold this flight more than anyone.
Man,
this is nuts.
I have to,
if I lose this next fight,
I'm screwed though.
A problem is it sets a precedent.
Now,
if I'm looking at it from a,
as a businessman,
if I was,
if I was a businessman,
let's pretend,
okay,
I would say this sets a precedent.
You can't let someone decide what press they don't press.
They don't do like you have an obligation to fulfill certain responsibilities
like with the media for sure.
Like,
like create hype.
But the question is,
but the question is like when do those responsibilities move into like a purely
digital realm and when do those responsibilities only in showing up places,
physically old school,
retro going places.
Because like there's nothing wrong with the occasional press conference,
right?
No,
but,
but also you can accomplish way more with a few fucking viral videos than you
ever could.
Going to some weird interview with two people that aren't MMA fans.
And I think he made a really good point about that.
Doing this fucking these morning shows,
they make them go do where you know,
nobody knows who the guy is or the girl,
they don't give a shit about MNA.
Yeah,
they don't,
they don't want to talk to him the way you want to talk to him.
Or I want to talk to him,
you know,
and I'm talking to Connor like before a fight.
I'm,
I'm trying to find out what's going on in the head of a guy who's going to
engage.
One of the most exciting things that I'm going to see all year.
No,
you're not going on a morning show going.
How about that cauliflower?
Huh?
How'd you get that?
Shut the fuck up.
But also like that.
I know,
but congress is a guy where he's crossed over into pop culture.
He's such a big star now.
A tweet from him.
We'll hype the fight if I guarantee if Connor Dana had conversation and Dan was
like,
all right man,
I understand it's a big fight cause you got to remember if you were to lose this
one,
now you're losing your golden boy.
The biggest star by far by far.
I also feel like he could just focus.
Let's just let him focus a little bit.
Why I also feel like the magnitude of this,
the dilemma that's in front of him and Nate Diaz is also very apparent.
This is not a guy you can half ass.
And even if you are 100% ready,
you've never even fought him at 100% Oh,
you fought him when he had 11 days.
Notice what he'd been drinking in Mexico.
I mean he posted typical matchup man.
And then you want to fly him on a plane.
Did anyone think?
Man,
all right.
If you're looking at them with three months away though,
okay,
but still Connor's exhausted man from doing this stuff.
And also,
you know,
I see some fighters go,
it's our obligation to do these press conferences slowly.
Roll Homie,
you're not Conor Mcgregor press conference.
That's a big difference.
And,
and,
and uh,
lost to him.
You're talking millions and the UFC,
if I'm looking at as a businessman,
I go,
all right,
all right man.
Hell,
he's gonna do a press conference,
but we're going to come to him.
Did anyone think to do that?
Well,
first of all,
Connor is one of the most charismatic guys,
seriously of all time in all sports.
No doubt about it.
I mean,
he is a fucking marketing machine.
Like they're just the quotes in his style,
his tweet player interrupt you.
But his tweet is the biggest tweet by an athlete this year.
Beat Koby Bryant's retirement tweet and you want me to go do a fucking interview
for ESPN?
Well,
they don't know the sport.
Oh as well.
I watch ESPN every morning.
They were talking about Lebron James The playoff game tonight.
They interrupted this shit with breaking news top out.
Connor's not retiring.
That's how big he is now.
The PR team at UFC could not get this.
They could not get this sort of attention.
Even if they want to.
Connor can.
It's a different age,
man.
Those old interviews,
that else press conference.
You have a legit fucking superstar man who makes more money than anyone.
The ice skates.
Totally.
What I was going to say,
sorry.
Series points.
It's okay a sometimes I just go now where you know you,
you have a,
you have all good points are all valid points and I get this contracts,
I get stuff like that,
but there has to be where you can't have a pissing contest.
You can't say,
well,
we're going to run it like a business this time and then not this time because
it's good for the company with Conor Mcgregor and this big of a fight.
If he wins this dude,
you know how much more money you're gonna make,
not the fucking press conference.
[inaudible] you're absolutely right that he's one of the most charismatic guys
were all time.
But Nate Diaz right now is God damn gigantic.
And I think we're going to realize he's not as big.
It's kind of close,
but he's goddamn gigantic.
He's huge.
And see what happens.
That's because of that.
That's part of that fight.
Part of that fight is that Connor is also fighting another mercurial superstar
character.
I agree.
Especially now after the first fight.
I agree Joe,
but let's say Connor doesn't fight at UFC 200.
And,
uh,
let's say Nate fights Woodley or Robbie Lawler.
Let me know how this rating scale and we know even pray fight at one 70 animals.
Let's say at one 55,
let's say fights.
Dos Anjos let me know how those ratings,
because here's where it won't be as close.
Oh,
we need to be a quarter of it.
I wonder.
It'd be close.
Maybe half.
I mean,
that's the sense that maybe half half makes sense,
but half would still be pretty spectacular,
you know,
at night,
even half.
Um,
I'm being generous and he's the biggest,
there's no doubt about it.
He's the Vegas.
Yeah.
Well who knows?
It's all speculation.
But here's what's interesting.
They offered the fight apparently to normal go Madoff,
but he can't take it because it's only four days after Ramadan.
Fuck man.
So he's very religious,
so he does that whole fascinating.
I had a buddy of mine,
my friend Con clayly from back in Boston.
He used to do that shit.
He's training.
He would do that.
Um,
he would fast when he was training,
it was crazy.
You just,
you,
you have certain rules where you're not allowed to eat anything.
What,
how's it go?
You're not allowed to eat anything or drink anything up.
Sun Down.
Right.
It upside down.
Do you see?
Do it?
Yeah.
And you can't,
there's no food or water.
And at like 6:00 PM,
they have this feast.
Yeah.
But it,
it can weaken you and so he'd be upset.
It would have a real,
it'd be a real problem if you had a fight.
Four or five rounds.
I get it and I would love to see that fight.
Habib,
Nigga Murdoch Verse Nate Diaz.
He's such a beast,
right?
He's phenomenal.
Yeah.
To us who are balls deep in the UFC world.
Yes.
No,
you're right.
Espn and covering that fight.
Dude,
you should start a promotion.
Look at you.
You're a God damn promoter.
You know how to do this.
I'm not.
I've been through it and when I see a guy like Conor comes in once in a
lifetime,
if you think there'd be another condom at Gregor,
you're bat shit crazy.
I think when we invest in arts,
the UFC,
they keep going.
I think you're crazy.
I think Conor is a special dude and I think there's a few other,
I think Brock Lesnar was,
I think Rhonda is,
there's,
there's very few players.
Is it possible that this is a calculated gamble based on not thinking he has
enough time to prepare for Nate?
No,
I don't think some possible impulses just just as just a matter of digging your
heels into the ground and saying,
there's no,
there's no way I can do this much percent.
I think he's just like,
dude,
I'm exhausted.
You and me on this world tour is it?
Can I please get ready for this?
It's not the WWE man.
Go,
go,
ask,
go ask a major superstar Lebron and I know you think it's not the same,
but Lebron,
any of these guys,
these superstars in Sports Ranalda gone.
These world tours not get paid.
Sell the fight when like put my social media will cover way more than this.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But we have no one fighting like he,
he can't say anything.
You say anything.
Look,
you got pulled from the car.
So more is not better is a certain amount of a certain amount you do.
We had a certain amount.
You're doing it for the UFC.
You're not doing it for the Conor McGregor brand.
You're not doing for the fighters brand.
You think by him going to ESPN,
he's going get more followers.
Would you think that there's like there's certain consideration that looked like
it looks good to have file of fighters show up on ESPN.
He's been there,
he's on,
he's on breaking news.
He's,
he's,
he's been doing it maybe the week before,
do it.
But when he wants to prepare for a camp and you have a guy of his magnitude
coming off a loss and he's like,
man,
I really think doing all this press and all this stuff has fucked with my
capabilities to be a fight.
I need to get back to that.
Will you please let me focus?
It makes it very hype.
The fight.
It totally makes sense.
Well you can't have exceptions.
No,
no mother fucker.
You can cause you do make exceptions.
Well here's what,
you have certain people in the UFC roster where they can't,
you know what I'm saying?
Where they pick and choose when they fight or who they fight.
There are exceptions.
Right.
And here's another thing to Kate and take into consideration.
One of the most important things that anybody,
any athlete does while they're in training is get proper rest.
It's one of the most important things and what fucks up when you go traveling
all the time.
Your rest.
So number one thing that wrecks you,
you know,
let me think how much you travel too.
I just,
I just flew in from Seattle this morning.
I got up at five this morning,
flew here,
got right off the plane and drove right in here.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what happens man.
You're,
your body gets a,
your immune system gets jack from that.
It's all good.
I just think of the,
I think this is great for the sport,
a good discussion to have because now future superstars will say,
I'm only doing this,
may interviews this,
this much before the fight.
Well maybe when all of the sink going to happen.
Maybe there's a debate.
Maybe the debate could be held as to like what is the,
what's the amount that you need to do once the amount that you should do,
you know,
like what,
how do you have it set up and what would be the,
what would be the best way for the performance of the athlete,
the consideration of their,
their,
their time.
And focus to put 100% effort into something and not leave anything on the table
because they really weren't rested enough cause we were or distracted too much.
Cause they're doing too much press.
But who is it?
Who's it helping the end?
The UFC and Dana white light by using paper view.
If they have pay per view buys and they get a percentage of the buys,
it helps.
It helps everyone.
But,
but if the fighter,
I mean there should be a direct,
there's a direct if a fighter as a percentage of pay per view with which guy
like Conor does.
Yes.
The more paper view deals where maybe he does it a title fight.
We don't know what his deal is.
So I'm talking about the pantry you buys for sure.
I would have smacked her.
Why?
I would assume yes.
Um,
but so the more press he does,
the more things get sold,
the more money he makes.
But in his point of view,
like tweets and things that he's doing right now are getting more attention to
it than any of these stupid interview going to pay for this kind of,
you can't,
and you can't argue with that.
That's absolutely true,
but the question is like,
where were,
you know there should be like a contract and the contract should state from x to
y.
You know,
pick a date and time.
I would be left alone if you saw it or wants to get me.
I'll be up in Iceland freezing my deck off thrown sidekicks,
come get me.
I see.
I think this whole thing is a misspeak miscommunication.
I see Dana side and I see countersigned right as a fight.
I definitely see Connor side.
I think it's just a miscommunication.
I think if before all this came out,
if Conner was like,
listen man,
I can't be doing all this fucking,
I guarantee you have Dana was sitting right.
There would be no miscommunication.
I don't think.
I don't think he would agree that it was a miscue communication.
I think he would say the Connor just does want to do the press and I got to do
the press.
And to me that's a miscommunication.
But can I get some miscommunications,
a disagreement?
No,
I disagree because I eat,
I disagree.
And this is why Joe,
because I think after,
after,
even though we fought Aldo,
he expressed,
do I need to chill on these interviews?
He,
he beats a Nate Diaz or he loses Nate Diaz again.
He's like,
dude,
this fucking press is killing me.
So He's been voice in it.
And I don't know if his camp has had the discussion with Dana,
but at some point maybe they haven't.
We don't know.
Maybe his total speculation,
miscommunication down and come up with a schedule.
I guess you got to leave me alone for eight weeks.
But he,
but what if,
what if Dana and Connor had a conversation right now,
man to man and Cognito's listen,
what I'll do,
I'll film videos every day.
I'll do this after my practices.
I'll put all this social media out for you guys.
Craig,
this fight,
no one has the pull that I do,
right?
And I can create this many views for millions and millions.
No other fighter can,
don't pay me for it.
Just don't make me travel.
You don't think Dana and the UFC would agree to any of this?
I bet.
I bet they'd be open to it.
You know,
it's interesting,
Kevin Hart,
he was like one of the biggest stars in the world,
one of the biggest,
uh,
comedians ever as far as like sales and volume,
like 90,
no one even close.
I mean,
he,
he crushes it.
He sells out.
Like,
what is that like 50,000 plus soldier field?
It's nuts.
Anyway,
um,
that's not important.
What's important is he's,
he's like gigantic on social media,
super active,
and he does it all himself.
So if he does a movie,
like he'll do a movie and they'll say,
oh great,
and you can use your,
you know,
5.8 million social media followers and a,
it'll boost up the movie.
And it was like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
That's mine.
No,
if you want that.
Yup.
And we've got to talk about that first guy to dude.
They like all the people that were in those movie meetings must have been like,
oh shit.
Because then the rock goes,
Huh?
Yeah.
Because there's a giant difference between a guy like the rock,
like what he can do to sell a movie with social media and the average person,
the average actor,
I mean he's,
he's constantly on it.
He has a dedicated loyal fan base because he's really funny and self deprecating
follows us,
works hard.
So he's shown pictures of,
of the alarm clock.
It says like four 15 in the morning and he's up there fucking doing dead lifts.
He's an animal,
right?
So a guy like that,
that's a business on the side,
that's his,
like he's got a hype business as well as a business to promote himself,
but he can also hype things.
You know,
he's not promotion once he give me some money when he does that,
I'm sure he's got it worked.
It was talking about it.
And it's got to worked into movies now.
So it's like,
Oh,
if you want a part of the Kevin Hart money machine that I put together,
well you gotta give me something bitch.
Like she kind of be any different.
You're right,
you're right in that respect as,
as,
as a superstar now not every fiber can pull that card.
You legitimately have to be able to sell out giant stadiums and be a superstar.
Yeah.
And he certainly can,
especially if you give them the right match ups,
you know,
if you give Connor the right match up at one 45 like I think honestly,
I mean I'm excited about this Nate Diaz fight cause I like watching them fight.
I like watching Nate Diaz fight.
I like,
and I love the attention he's getting,
but if I was,
if I was in Connor's camp,
I mean I understand that he's obsessed and he wants to get right back at it.
I would say go fight Frankie Edgar,
go fight Max Holloway.
Have a rematch of Max Holloway.
That shit would be epic if Aldo,
whoever Aldo does,
you know,
and they mix it all up a fight,
a rematch with all dumb.
All those been talking mad shit about him,
you know,
I think all go genuine and genuinely believes that he fucked up.
And if he gets a hold of this dude this time he get punished them,
which is awesome.
Fight and awesome story.
I want to see it.
I want to see homeowners can't think those sites are still gonna be there if he
leaves his Nate Diaz.
I think it takes some of the,
it takes a stock.
A lot of the star power already got taken away.
Too much of a risk.
It's just way too much power got taken away.
And that second fight,
not 100%,
he's still the biggest draw,
but he was,
uh,
an assassin before that fight on [inaudible].
Whether there was something going on,
like when he flatlined,
although with one punch and then did it,
like it was nothing and smiled and I was talking to him when the interview and
he's just saying,
you know,
no power,
just,
just put it,
put it right where it's the,
her,
anything like it.
Yeah,
I mean the way he gobbled up the pressure and the way he controlled the shit
talking.
This is the thing,
Joe,
we've,
we've never had a guy of his capabilities and his mass appeal go,
man,
I don't want to do this.
Like everyone else has jumped through these hoops.
I don't.
I want to fucking train,
man.
This is ridiculous.
I'm already big enough.
We've never had a guy really do this.
He's also a guy where I think if he wanted to,
if he was involved with the UFC,
let's say Dana,
which would never happen.
Cut Goes,
go do what the fuck you.
I'm sick.
You go do what you want.
He could sell out a giant arena in Dublin against Datta 5,000 every Saturday.
That's how powerful he is.
That's what I literally make and just make more and more money.
Well,
I don't know about that because I think part of the excitement about him was
building up to that Aldo fight.
That was part of the man who would be king.
Story was that he was going to fight the longtime king and when he flat the
longtime king,
he reached this level of legendary popularity.
There does that.
It happens once in a hundred generations when it comes with fighters,
right?
There's this,
this is moment,
this boom.
How many guys reached that moment?
Like when he flatlined Aldo with one punch and then it was 13 seconds of the
whole world was like,
he fucking did it.
The answer is none did it?
Yes,
it's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
that was epic.
But the lustre gets taken off by the Nate Diaz fight and if he loses to Nate
Diaz,
he's got a very good point that,
you know,
he can't lose because he wasn't given the right amount of opportunity to present
or to,
um,
to prepare himself because he had to do all this press,
like right now,
the Conor McGregor fan base and guys hugging his nuts,
which I might be one of them,
but he,
you know,
they're going,
well,
you know,
Nate Diaz is way bigger and he kind of caught him off guard.
Well,
all that good.
And there's a little asterisk I guess if you're this Conor guy,
well now if he loses again,
there's no more excuses because the fuck there's no astrick.
Nate had 11 I'm saying it.
You could,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm not saying there is Nate.
Straight up beat them with 11 days preparing sip and coronas on a boat and came
and whooped his ass.
I thought ne was going to beat him just by first of all the size and length and
deceptive boxing skills.
That's not what I thought.
I was like,
this is going to be the first guy that Connor's ever fought that's been in wars
with like a legends.
I mean he's been in there with a lot of fucking super high level dude.
He's a monster and like this is a big,
big fight and this is not a fight you want to take.
Even if he's not ready on 11 days notice,
you got to get ready for this dude and his Jujitsu is off the chain.
Man.
His Jujitsu is at a super high level and she's bigger than comment.
There couldn't be a worse match up bars with Andre Ward,
world champion and Joe showing on a regular basis.
I know him and his brother Nick.
I know Gilbert Melendez,
Jace Shield,
no joke,
no joke.
Dangerous fucking fight,
man.
Whore.
What's stressing me out?
Fuck with Adrian.
But the guy who we're not talking about in all this is Nate Diaz.
Cause even though if Nate Diaz and you guys can say whatever you want,
you'll see 200 still going to be dope.
I get that.
That's all fun and Dandy for the the absolute fans.
If there's no Connor,
Nate doesn't make the same pay day.
So he gets fucked man.
You're right.
And I want to see the,
the dues that Nate has paid.
And remember the Diaz brothers were the first guys to go.
Not Fuck that man.
I don't think it should be done that way.
And you got appreciate that man in a,
in a land full of fucking sheep.
They were the first kind of wolves go,
no,
fuck that man.
This ain't right.
Well they're also the first guys to put a ridiculous emphasis on extreme cardio.
Yes.
And it shows in their style.
Yeah.
I mean like nick doing marathons and triathlons and a,
I was,
it's funny,
I keep quoting and nick corrected me the other day.
I said that he swam back from Alcatraz twice.
He just correct me the other day.
It was five times.
Now it's fucking nuts.
Five times he swam from Alcatraz to the fucking mainland.
They didn't think you could do that.
They didn't think it was possible.
That's why they put a prison there cause they didn't think people could swim.
Well this mother fucker is a stoner and an athlete.
These aren't even a prisoner.
Oh fucking let,
don't lock that dude.
I was going to swim right the fuck out.
He oh quickly on a bunch of guys like him in prison.
But how crazy are people these days do be doing things for recreation?
The only,
the only guy who could bring Nate Diaz money is George Saint Pierre Grc parent.
Yeah,
I agree.
I think we might begin honey Dick,
if George Saint Pierre does happen just shell up at UFC 200 it's like,
wait a sec.
Well,
George has openly said that he wants to go to a camp and decide whether or not
he could do it.
At the end of it,
he's done it.
Did he go through the,
the prep camp?
That's what I heard.
When did you hear this?
You got the inside scoop.
Dot.
I mean,
I know he's been training a shit load and I know he doesn't care about belts or
anything.
He just wants to take the fight.
You know what the holdup is?
Why Reebok?
Okay,
that's awful.
Oh,
well you're George Saint Pierre sponsored by under Armour.
And then how many fights do you have?
And Reebok's.
And we're like,
yeah,
here's whatever,
50 grand where these Reebok pumps.
He's like,
what the fuck?
No Man,
I'm George Saint Pierre.
So he's saying either the USC has to make up for it in his purse or Reebok has
make up for it.
So I think it's a money thing right now.
Really?
That's what you hear is this inside scoop.
I don't know,
man.
We just scooped a shit out of this.
That's what I hear.
Well,
I had been hearing rumblings of negotiations,
but uh,
you know,
it's one of those things you don't want to hope he wanted to just wait,
but also I only got,
you can save the code.
Well he would,
he would most certainly saved the card.
Oh my God.
You know,
it would be crazy.
Would be him and,
and Connor.
I man,
that's fucking nuts.
Tim.
Encounter Madison Square Garden to what you would,
it was not enough seats there.
No,
there'd be full of just fucking GSP versus it looked like the Oscars is just be
as crowd full of celebrities.
Regular folk can afford the tickets,
especially if you get angry GSP GSP that wanted to punish Bj Penn GSP.
I think it's really tough to bring it out.
But you didn't like rush rush.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
He was a motherfucker.
Oh,
GSP was one of the weirder guys because he was such a nice guy at all times slot
when guys fucked with him.
There was this,
this switch that would go off in that head and he would go on seek and destroy
mode and he was so good at it.
Man when he fucked up Bj Penn fucked up Fitch,
you,
you wash those fights and you just go,
that is arguably the greatest welterweight of all time.
I agree.
I mean,
his ability to mix up the strikes and the take downs.
We never knew what the fuck was going on.
His,
his constant victories and a scrambles,
you know,
and the Bj fight to where he was punishing Bj,
he wanted to punish him.
And when he,
when he beat him down and didn't stop them and then walked over to the wall and
fucking punched it afterwards,
that's the motherfucker now.
Does he come back or do we get that that safe GSP cause a safe GSP verse condom?
We're not trying,
I'm not trying to see that.
There's a lot,
there's a long time gone.
Who knows?
Who knows where G we're talking about GSP and Bj.
Bj Penn's coming back to,
yeah,
well I'm a,
I'm excited to see what that looks like.
Bj's fight in Tennessee.
Vre and he's been at Jackson Winkeljohn his camp for quite a while now.
So I'm assuming they're not letting him cut any corners.
Uh,
not really running them through the real paces.
If,
if you're at Jackson's,
there's no cutting corners.
If you do your skin,
you're asked Molly Wahpeton,
then you wouldn't be there that long.
Right.
And get back on a plane,
go home.
And why would he,
I mean he's been living out there for quite a while now.
Hawaii down.
That'd be pretty legit.
GSP Negotiating Uba.
UFC returned,
but Reebok deal considers roadblock or there's a story.
Mm hmm.
Yeah man.
I don't know.
Just this whole thing bums me out.
It was complicated.
We'll see.
We'll see what happens.
But man,
hope you can.
That would be the 200 to end it.
If you think you saved from asking square guy and fuck,
do you think that would be Nate versus GSP of Connor doesn't do the car.
So Connor's not on the card anymore.
He's off today.
He said I'm down to fight.
He even goes,
I will fly to New York and do a press conference,
but then I gotta go back.
So he's given a little wiggle room.
I think it's time to drop the egos come to agreement and save 200 let Connie
[inaudible] name is Brennan Shab the reasonable one.
How is this possible haired dude houses fossil Kenogenic Diet?
Kido kid,
I was super positive.
Super clear mind.
I like everyone and I hope they work that out for UFC 200 it'd be even better
story if they're worked there too.
They do get,
they do.
I would almost guarantee they do or they do a GSP Nate Diaz fight.
Then we got honey dick and then something smells fishy.
Something smells fishy for sure.
If GSP is like,
what?
Hey,
I've been training.
What if they come with the cash that come with that fucking Reebok makeup money?
I bet you,
I bet you everybody has a set of Reebok pumps in 6 million share.
You go push it in for us.
Shit in.
We're all in for GSP.
I think a,
I bet they figured it out.
Yeah,
I bet.
I Bet Yukon or ends up fighting on UFC 200
that's why.
That's what I believe in,
and that's,
I think Dana and the UFC brass gonna figure it out.
I think GSP Nate Diaz takes its place and they use it as a negotiating tool
because the paper view numbers are bigger than any of the Connor fights because
the UFC has in fact grown through their strategy.
See,
I don't think the numbers beat Connors.
What if they do?
Well,
then you got,
then,
hey,
then Connor's GSP and Nate Diaz that you're like,
Ooh,
Connor fucked up.
Yeah,
I kind of fucked up.
I don't think it beats as numbers though.
[inaudible].